fallout for everybody loaded up in their
cars and heading out to the desert and
they brought awesome camera to shoot on
Gavin showed up to help out in the
slow-motion they had a phantom have all
these props but the one thing they
didn't seem to bring was a freaking
microphone hey hey
we brought a mic we brought a mic but it
was broken and so the microphone that we
had as a backup didn't actually work
with the red it only worked with Canon
DSLR so we were like well we can't do
anything about that and what did you
shoot the BTS on hey hey don't give me
that kind of for fallout 4 we are
going to be building holy studio in Sam
and Nico's office so that we can
recreate every single sound that we
would have gotten on the day but with
more effort and more time footsteps
Gavin's vault 111 jumpsuit Jake's dog
noises I don't even know how we're gonna
do those but we'll figure out a way the
gun build all those elements in or else
it's going to feel like a very empty
it's going to feel more like a Jif than
a video gotta build your own home fully
sound replacement studio first you need
a microphone want to make sure the mic
is pointed where the sound is going to
be coming from right there and now right
here is going to be the studio itself so
you want to make sure when you're
building your supercro fully sound
studio that you maintain utmost
professionalism so you want to make sure
that you create the different
environments you know you you kind of
maintain a one-for-one recreation of the
desert so this is how we're going to do
that
yeah that's right better this is part
two this is the most important part you
want to make sure you do this absolutely
correct
so after preparing all morning for this
went to a couple different spots to get
all the materials we needed think we're
ready to put the finishing touches on
our studio and there's a professional
Foley studio top of this list before I
get it all into my shed let's frame up
the shot just because it's really
awkward to do this here's the technique
you have to employ when directing Sam
you just think of him as a cat don't
worry about continuity it's not your job
like directing a cat if you can get the
cat to focus on something it'll become
super engaged and curious the point the
point where props they're not your job
like a neko specifically said this
morning we all started that he wanted
everyone to keep track of their here
everyone's been doing a great job of
doing that
except percent
the Wildcat in this native environment
seems to be content for the time being
he has a vaporizer you never know what
he might strike out even doing about
your stuff for now just immortals
rehearse step that way your like off his
line
Sam come for just a little bit Sam so
just do it a little earlier go ahead and
straighten up sim why are we doing this
again we're doing something else you
guys these guys have pads I can do that
or a knee pad ah Bren what's your
favorite Christmas sir the corridor
digital Christmas sweater I could buy it
now get it before it's too late
oh no I was thinking on the green one
but then I'm like no that might be a
little too green for me was the black
one I think I prefer the blue one over
the black bum
can I go with the blue one get a little
bit of that Christmas blue cheer wow
they're too fast
one of the things that I learned early
on in filmmaking was uh modulating my
steps so that I could send me like
someone walking running you know I'll
demonstrate give me any kind of walking
straight straight yeah okay now do one
you're a drunkard aha and your uncle
beat you when you were a child and
you've always drawn on that and always
had a kind of grudge against society
what was he was he beating me because he
was angry at me or was he beating me
because he hated himself movie magic
what's your process for being able to
sync up the footsteps so once we've got
our studio set up we want to use a
program that will allow us to record
audio to picture that the performer in
this case me can see the steps that
Gavin's taking and try and recreate them
as faithfully as possible so this is the
most important part you just want to
press record it really quick run over to
the box so that you're ready
okay now ready when I was a little I
would do like the sound effects two
movies at me my family we're watching we
couldn't afford speakers when I was
little I would add the sound effects
after the fact which is really proud of
what we've done today you know it's
moments like these where I'm just like
this is why I got into this you know
this is why I do this
it's the holidays and you got to sure
the holiday spirit with some good video
game references on a t-shirt in classic
ugly sweater form it's great
you'll love it it's weird they almost
look like like helmets from Halo what's
the other snowflake made of on the cord
or sweater okay okay so they are they
are the halo plasma swords it's pretty
cool
got the mario star and the Mario coin
have some Minecraft creeper heads we got
Microsoft Windows oh I'm an idiot let's
try to scroll by doing this
one action
I mean somewhere
great oh it's really good it's called
where'd you learn to fool like that
skateboarding I will be playing Reinhard
I think Reinhard is about four times as
large as I am but I'll try to have a big
on-screen presence
hopefully Nico is kind and shoots me
kind of from an up angle to add some
math yeah there we go exactly ah yeah I
am I feel bigger eyelid now I just need
those muscles glistening in the Sun oh
my god
bigger already and it's all thanks to
Gabe my friend Gabe here he knows how to
raise a man's self-esteem in no time
Reinhardt can boost this I figure to
make something to do it on boosted board
and as Hudson bananaboy Stoker
be like like this yeah take your time
figured out our to it button here will
go like three to go to flat down there
don't hurt yourself
then help me help sell your free point
you're running backwards from there we
go
you're riding backwards Phil oh I am
three two one action aah
good you gave me good cover but you see
me morph like wow and then I'm saying
gotcha
good that's very clean thing about the
effects not good you happy here's your
gonna work out Sam pushing cars dude
that's what I used to do
I pushed cars for like two summers on a
high school man why push them man I
don't know it's great for shooting my
tripod broken my wagon stolen my lens
cracked your dignity my dignity gone it
was never there to begin with let's be
honest the only thing you have now is
this sweet quarter Digital Christmas
sweater I don't even have that yet